hi Hulu fans it's Gordon don't miss the
season premiere of Next Level Chef
straight after the Super Bowl on Fox and
Stream next day on Hulu you're all here
to fight for the title of Next Level
chef
[Music]
season two of Next Level Chef is
extraordinary refining the best of
social media home cooks and professional
chefs competing on three levels for a
one-year mentorship with Gordon Ramsay
Naisha Arrington and myself Richard
blais and 250
000 this is the ultimate Proving Ground
we have some of the absolute best chefs
in the country the contestants are
amazing
the judges are feistier on the platform
now
this season is totally different you can
save yourself from elimination with an
immunity pin we have immunity pins we
have time tokens wow maybe you get a
Time token you get a little bit more
time for yourself they are taking things
up to the next level we on Next Level
Chef baby you can head on over to the
lounge
the team and the chefs who win get to go
hang out in the lounge to watch the
elimination they both have concerned
it's loungy that's nice
since I won last season I think Gordon
and Richard they're really trying to up
their game you two are in for a rough
ride you boys don't know what you're
talking about I don't think it's gonna
happen this year in Aisha and Gordon no
has anyone enough I'm not good at losing
I
I'm not too I'm done that first episode
is one not to be missed we've got one of
the biggest lead-ins on the planet the
Super Bowl on Fox is there a more
coveted spot it doesn't get any bigger
than that
[Music]